[Music]
it's bashing time hey everybody thanks
just a moment you've all been waiting
for
I lost to say file and I can't be funny
okay but let's play I want to be Boss
sheets oh it's so hard oh it's so hard
all right here's a tutorial like I
haven't figured that out what that sure
I know how to play a game
oh no I don't know I can't do the
tutorial oh no oh oh this is bad oh look
at that easy shooting you 62 should have
pull it with what what that
[Music]
save jump it can be done by oh shoot a
same point hey I did it
god damn I'm a genius I see I don't need
those go away from me okay here we go
everybody ain't good
oh great
no I go back here are you kidding me
alright alright
so that wasn't actually a save that's so
annoying oh my god what did I go oh my
god okay alright what if I go over it
now okay
are you kidding me alright okay you
can't do anything where do I go where do
I go home oh my god
so annoying stop being so annoying
alright don't jump I'm just gonna okay
okay where am I what okay all right
where am I what killed me here last time
I have no idea okay
Oh God are you kidding me that looks
super difficult I don't even see how
great good job good job
oh my god of course why don't I just
shoot it there did the save just shoot
me back try this what are you gonna do
now huh what might I do this oh the game
is the game is slowing down a game can
you you can stop you can stop now game
oh god oh oh it's not boshy time
[Applause]
[Music]
don't want boshy time I don't want it I
don't want it anymore
wait f3 changes my character what the
hell I'm Way too slow reven it's fashion
and why is he so mean come on this is
easy this that is easy bit
I forgot that I needed to go to the
places didn't you frickin Frick I mean
sorry you two it's fine alright don't
worry about me worry about yourself but
have you ever worried about yourself
before maybe that's why you're a slob
sitting at home watching YouTube videos
you loser I'm a winner
okay I'm a winner look at this mending
jab Lafitte tan si habla feat caca I
think I think this game might be a
little difficult I don't know I don't
know what what what I wanted to say
about the game it might be a Mike you
can't even suck my own I can't even do
the first thing I can't even give you
the first thing 90 times
[Music]
look at thee look at these man this is
great this is great this is great this
is great this is great this is just what
I want this is what I wanted he wanted a
challenge this is not even that
difficult we're on the French jump boots
doing the face that debenture fine what
the hell were you thinking come on come
on
[Music]
I really should give up never never quit
I ain't a winner how am I getting worse
[Music]
de nada and going in you super-close
slips up scattered a man in my name bill
the harlot the Sonora
yamaneika I can't do it I know I can
I just need to do it once and then I
know I can do okay that's how it works
maybe recording where did it go where
evolution is taking us god damn it come
on I can't even do the first jump I
can't do the first jump I just can't I
can't do it I just can't do it
I just cannot how are you this bad be
quiet be quiet
all right I don't need you talking to me
like that come on give you some
encouragement damn it Joe yes I can do
it
look at me go
easy look at that [ __ ] look at it I am
dead inside